- Les rues de la petite
communauté crie de Maskwacis,
au sud d'Edmonton, avait
besoin d'une nouvelle couche
d'asphalte depuis longtemps.
La visite du pape
aura finalement poussé
le gouvernement de l'Alberta à
débloquer les fonds nécessaires.
Mais ici, lieu du premier
arrêt du pape au pays,
ce qu'on tentera de réparer
n'a rien de cosmétique.
Luci Johnson nous montre
le terrain où se trouvait
jadis le pensionnat Ermineskin.
Son père y a subi
de nombreux abus.
La visitLa visitLa visite et der
place du pape ne suffiront pas
à faire disparaître sa colère.
À Maskwacis, les leadersde la ct
le fait que le pape s'arrête
chez eux pour reconnaître
les torts de l'Église,
même si cette visite, qui ravive
de nombreux traumatismes,
ne fait pas l'unanimité.
"L'expérience ne sera pas
positive pour tout le monde",
souligne Luci Johnson.
Lieu de pèlerinage catholique
pour les Métis et les
Premières Nations de l'ouest,
le lac Sainte-Anne occupait déjà
une place importante dans la
spiritualité autochtone avant
l'arrivée du christianisme.
Que le pape François vienne
y prier avec les Autochtones
envoie un bon message,
croit le chef local.
Répéter des excuses pour
les pensionnats viendra
confirmer une fois pour toutes
les terribles souffrances
longtemps ignorées
ou remises en question.
Tony Alexis aurait aimé
que le pape reste au
lac Sainte-Anne plus longtemps.
Mais il souhaite surtout que
l'humilité dont il fait preuve
durant son séjour au Canada
laissera sa marque sur
l'ensemble de l'Église
catholique.
De passage en Alberta,
le pape fera aussi
un arrêt dans cette église
du centre-ville d'Edmonton.
Lourdement endommagée par
un incendie il y a deux ans,
cette église dédiée aux
Premières Nations, aux Métis et
aux Inuits rouvre ses portes
juste à temps pour la visite
papale.
L'aîné Fernie Marty s'y sent
encore plus chez lui alors que
la reconstruction achève.
Chaque élément architectural
porte une signification
autochtone particulière,
une façon de dire que, malgré
le traumatisme des pensionnats,
les Autochtones du Canada
ont leur place au sein
de l'Église catholique.
Fernie Marty comprend que,
pour plusieurs, la douleur
et la colère persistent.
Mais il préfère voir dans cette
visite une occasion à saisir.
- La réconciliation
est vraiment possible.
- Si l'Église est sincère
dans sa démarche, tous les
Autochtones ne sont pas prêts
à se réconcilier avec elle,
reconnaît l'archevêque
d'Edmonton.
RICHARD SMITH,
archevêque d'Edmonton
- Il faut rencontrer la personne
où la personne se trouve,
la respecter et, de ce moment-là
trouver des manières
d'avancer ensemble.
- Recevoir la visite du chef
de l'Église demeure un événement
joyeux pour les catholiques
canadiens, croit
le coordonnateur général
de la visite papale.
Mais il assure que la raison
de ce séjour du pape au Canada
ne sera pas éclipsée.
- La teneur de cette visite
est vraiment sombre.
Il y a un sentiment pénitentiel
à travers tout ça.
- À Maskwacis, la visite
du pape François ne durera
que quelques heures.
Les excuses du pape
marqueront une avancée
vers la réconciliation.
Mais il faudra du temps
pour en mesurer l'impact.
Construire le chemin
de la gu